I'm here in lindo at the 59th meeting of
Nobel laureates following a week of
solid sunshine we've just had a
torrential downpour and a fierce thunder
and lightning storm weather's always but
inherently variable and Congress has
changed over millennia so perhaps it's
not surprising but what we know now is
the climate is changing at an
unprecedented rate and scientists say
that were to blame so what can we do
about it most experts not your
scientists now but economists and
politicians and so on the consensus
being that it would be wise to attempt
for the temperature the surface
temperature not to rise above two
degrees over the past week I've met some
of the best minds in science who are
turning their attention to this problem
joining me have been three young
enthusiastic researchers all working on
various aspects of climate change and
wondering what they can do to solve the
problem I'm working with catalyst in a
new process to make biodiesel that makes
it much more environmentally friendly
more economical and more portable so
that we can actually bring it two
countries and develop sustainable
economies around this technology we are
running out of time the climate is
affected so much and we have got to do
something about it and the Sun is a
major source of energy has been for the
last so many centuries the Egyptians
worshipped the Sun as they thought it
was the source of all energy and it is
the why can't we utilize its energy for
the benefit of mankind I studied
Chemical oceanography and my research is
focused on the Gulf of Mexico hypoxic
zone I study the effects of nutrients
from the Mississippi River and the
increasing hypoxia in the estuary that
it runs into what interests me about
climate change is that what we do in one
part of the world may have impacts
downstream you know humans are also
impacting the rest of the ecology now we
did just a few days to find out of
meeting the laureates and
really change our ideas I guess we can
also learn from the last generation so
the laureates that are here this week
presumably will have some amazing
insights into you know into what we can
do I mean you must all have burning
questions for specific laureates I
imagine were the people who actually
discovered how did them until our
actions of the moment if we're serious
about addressing this problem
essentially you're talking about is
reinventing how humans interact with the
world and how we interact with each
other as well it's it's I think I see it
as that fundamental and that's where I
go back and forth from being optimistic
too pessimistic can we change our
fundamental behavior and be aware of our
impacts unless we talk about it we
cannot do something we cannot when you
don't think about something when you're
just like an ostrich knows no problem
are there a lot of ostriches in Pakistan
I mean two you field as well are afraid
yes yes and the developing world they
have they they are more focused on other
things they're more focused in progress
and infrastructure and education on the
health they can't afford to think about
climate what would we learn from the
Nobel Prize winning scientist that Linda
I think the first thing is to recognize
the scale of the problem I think it's
encapsulated in the fact that we use in
one year fossil fuel that took about a
million years to produce so basically
fossil fuel efficiency is casey's a
million years and we have to increase
our efficiency of capturing solar energy
and converting it into something that's
useful by a factor of ten to the six
there will be a tremendous pressure to
go for nuclear energy if it should
become a major direction of replacing
oil and gas would in mapping and have a
huge probability of leading to a
catastrophe what was interesting was
that they thought was you know to deal
with climate change we might actually
need to build many many nuclear power
plants and what with your societal
implications for Daffy and also there
was
question a nuclear proliferation and
this is such a great alternative to the
fossil fuels but you know we can't use
it because of the political and societal
implications we do need to you know just
thrown down unliving standards and I
don't think you have to sacrifice a
standard of living but you have to use
conserve
our next meeting was with two scientists
who won the Nobel Prize for work which
led to a worldwide ban on ozone
depleting CFC gases what could we learn
from the experience of Sherwood Rowland
now in his 80s and Mario Molina I guess
a lot of researchers who are working on
climate change or in the position where
their research is very policy relevant
what advice would you give them speak up
there's no one better informed than the
bong people involved themselves and so
they they should not be bashful about it
it seems like at least on the surface
you have very similar problems with you
know atmospheric interactions and
man-made gases but are the two problems
of the CFCs and carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere are they really that similar
or are they completely different
problems and we need to have different
solutions there they're much different
because of the magnitude of the co2
problem but it affects every use of
energy one could easily imagine
eliminating the use of CFC proponents
but you can easily imagine getting rid
of carbonaceous fuels since both of you
weathered the storm of the CFCs and
getting the policy passed through on
that and it was very successful how do
you view the carbon dioxide issue are
you optimistic allure is it almost too
big of a problem if we draw a lesson
from the from the ozone story which is
that first of all we have to be very
patient for any agreement to be reached
it was frustrating for a while and we
thought nothing could be done but I
guess recent prevails and some agreement
was reached although fight week at the
very beginning there is an opportunity
this year in Copenhagen to reach some
sort of agreement if we open the doors
maybe it will be an important step how
can you convince the people and the
government's from the developing
countries to actually focus their
resources more on countering climate
change when they have so many mouths to
feed the first important message is that
we're not talking about a competition
environment versus economic development
it's actually the other way around if
you look at predictions you look at
where we are heading it's going to be
much harder for developing countries
like Pakistan Bangladesh and zone will
have a harder time improving their
standards of living if climate change
materializes the way we think it might
the important message here is for
developing countries to recognize that
they will be better off if they
collaborate and participate in the
solution of the problem we've got two
approaches adaptation and mitigation and
as some of the mitigation strategies are
to remove co2 from the atmosphere and
sequester that what are some of these
sequestration methods that we can look
at co2 remains in the atmosphere for
almost the Millennium is not your
centuries that just means that we're
stuck with whatever we did already
unless we begin to take it out of the
atmosphere there are some ideas
chemically you can take it out although
at the substantial cost but it's
possible the research that you did
during your postdoc actually you know
got you a Nobel Prize and not everyone
is going to be that fortunate even
though they might persist and work very
hard you know what would you say they
need to keep going keep trying because
that I basically agree with Jerry but I
would add to it you have to do what you
like so do it with passion and we there
are so many important problems that
society is facing why not try to focus
on solving some of those problems what
from the part of your society do not
forget about fundamental science back in
1974 he both call for a worldwide bad on
CFCs now we're facing the problem of
climate change would you call for a
worldwide ban on coal plants or do you
believe the climate scientists should be
doing that as a responsible individual
who wants future generations to prosper
I would certainly call for her for a
band at the moment there's note because
these plants might be there for 50 years
so if I commit society to be submissions
for such a long time
if you have carbon capture and storage
so that you don't you aren't putting
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere with
that that's the real problem is putting
a greenhouse gas at least in the
atmosphere and not burying it
underground so if it can get it bury it
underground then you don't need to ban
that the burning in the first place but
did our young researchers agree with the
fees of these veterans
so here we are in a Linda bubble for a
week and it's an environment that
nurtures positivity and every one here
cares deeply about what's going on and
do you think it's a reflection of
reality really I think we need a breath
of optimism occasionally had to renew
our drive to find these solutions to
climate change I have a lot of faith in
the science and the science exists and
we can use the science but it comes down
to cost and where I'm more pessimistic
is with the people I mean are the people
going to be able to meet this problem
and you know just face the fact that
energy is no longer going to be cheap
and are which way you cut it whether we
run out of it or we have a new source is
going to be more expensive yesterday we
all had an opportunity to talk to
professor's Rowland and Molina and you
will have the opportunity to pose your
questions to them so I'm just wondering
how you found that dr. Molina was pretty
clear in that we're going to be that we
can meet global climate change with the
technology that we have now but at the
same time our biggest challenge is going
to be motivating people and policy and
actually getting getting the right
policies implemented I'm what about the
worldwide ban on codes do you think
about something that we he wasn't
exactly calling for a worldwide ban on
cold but on protect creating new coal
plants by not building new ones you're
forcing other technologies to be found
and to be utilized they both added the
caveat they're fine with it as long as
you find a way to sequester it but you
know I still yeah yeah and I'm working
with some of some of sequestration
technology it's to me it seems still so
far often so expensive to implement it
that you know I'm worried that we that
the technology is not there yet
on the last day everyone headed to the
nearby island of my no to hear a group
of experts discuss the science and
management of climate change among the
panelists were two scientists who won
the Nobel Peace Prize for their work on
climate change and also political
scientists buren lombourg who has gained
notoriety for his controversial views on
global warming the concentration of
greenhouse gases in the Earth's
atmosphere has reached unprecedented
levels we have to realize the enormity
of the problem if we get carried away
with the current pattern of development
without regard to the externalities the
harmful impacts that we're imposing on
the natural resources of this planet
then clearly we are leaving a world that
is unsustainable not just for future
generations but even in our lifetimes
how big of a problem is global warming
it is a problem yes if you look at the
economic models they estimate that the
damage from global warming is a neat in
the order of 15 to 25 trillion dollars
the total worth of the 21st century's
somewhat on the order of three thousand
trillion dollars so we're talking about
half of one percent of GDP in the 21st
century so global warming is certainly a
problem that we need to fix but perhaps
crucially it's probably not the most
important one that we can leave our
descendants with we cannot just measure
the damage for future generations in
terms of dollars among the most
worrisome threats that we have is the
threat of practically irreversible
changes to the climate we should
remember that carbon dioxide
concentration in the atmosphere today is
twenty-nine percent higher than ever in
the last 800,000 years what we now need
is actually to have a globally binding
climate target and deriving from that
target drastic emission reductions of
carbon dioxide we already now know from
science how much that would be in order
to for example me to climate target of 2
degrees Celsius we need everybody on
this planet
all countries on this planet by the year
2050 have reduced carbon dioxide
emissions by eighty percent I'm from
Pakistan how do you change attitudes the
developing countries they have other
priorities so the developed world take
the lead well firstly i agree with you i
think the developed nations who have to
take the first step you know i mean we
are from the same part of the world in a
slum in karachi or Mumbai what do people
have in their homes not a piece of
furniture but a television set what
files their aspirations the fact that
somebody is driving a swanky car or is
got an air conditioner in the home and
you know is I think what you really need
to see is the developed world making
major efforts to bring about the change
because climate change a problem
absolutely but when you work with in
climate change of course that's what
your main focus is but if you look
across all the different areas of the
world clearly yeah three-fourths of the
world's population live in abject
poverty they live in the medieval times
right now and to them it's probably more
important to get clean drinking water
food sanitation basic rights lake of
education and health care I work with a
company that's actually developed
sustainable biodiesel specifically for
developing communities if your product
actually does mean that these people can
make diesel biodiesel cheaper than they
could buy it it's a great product and I
would imagine a lot of countries around
the world we're going to take this up
really quickly but certainly many of the
products that we talk about usually our
products that are not nearly there and
so essentially the question is do we
want to have third world countries spend
lots of money on things that they didn't
really need compared to own schools
health care centers the problem is that
over the long haul we don't seem to be
able to find a way to stop using fossil
fuels I don't want to buy in efficient
technologies I want to pay you to make
much more efficient solar panel if you
could come up with solar panels that
would be cheaper than fossil fuels we'd
be done the do you think this is
because I mean we talked about it so
much there has been a lot of discussion
on it and we do anything that will get
translated into reality or that scope
and handsome is going to be success no I
don't think it's going to be a success
the way we look at it right now because
everybody comes to the table and says
these unrealistic numbers bottom line it
makes everybody all countries promise we
will do something that's harmful for us
that will mainly help everyone else in a
hundred years that's a very very hard
sell that's why everybody all
politicians love to promise stuff but
they won't actually do it we should much
more focus on investing money in you and
all three of you and a lot more to make
sure that you come up with the
technology so make it cheap enough for
everyone to buy it you know but the
bottom line really is that I suppose you
can't just measure the impact of climate
change and in dollars which was a point
that came up on the panel today how'd
you prioritize for example health / /
climate change you know what's your
rationale for your decisions you're
absolutely right it is important to say
when you try to measure problems in
dollars obviously it's not just about
productivity loss most people put most
importance to human lives but they also
put importance into wetlands and by the
biosphere in general obviously they care
about hypoxia and are willing to pay to
a boy toy box yeah so we try to put all
of those prices in there and come up
with a number and what our future
generations should we value those as
much as future and generation no no and
we don't okay and that's a very
important but it is very often sort of
broader we should care just as much for
future generations as we should for
present generation now that sounds
really nice but none of us do that how
does it feel when so many people
disagree with you it's not so much about
me being right or wrong it's about this
discussion being the right way to go
with the policy because what I really
fear is we failed in Kyoto we actually
failed in Rio before that and it seems
likely to me that we are going to fail
again in Copenhagen and waste another
ten years why on earth is that we're not
going to start thinking about maybe we
could do it differently maybe we could
do it smarter
so that was an interesting meeting edges
you feel about it I think it's very
prismatic and he could easily to the
White House to this point of view I I
don't think he sang he is actually he
held so controversial opinions actually
as his hands of the stage somehow I
could understand him much better wait in
a one-to-one conversation sure you
actually agreed with him from the point
of view of what people in developing
countries might actually need his
priorities I thought that was very
interesting conference actually he was
the only one who I was put on when the
attitudes of developing world was
concerned I mean no one even got near to
what people they all think but he had an
idea in like the United States which
still there's still a lot of people
thats a cold climate changes in a
problem we don't need to do anything
about it we don't even talk about it and
I'm worried that his message might you
know be used to support that coming back
to the like an overview of the hell week
and you know one of the highlights of it
for you listening to so many discussions
there and so many people here I do
believe maybe we cannot solve this
problem entirely but we can take small
steps and we can take those small steps
immediately so that's a good point I
feel like two mistakes one thing that
I've just come out is really
reinvigorated you know about the
sustainability as an issue there are a
lot of really smart people really
dedicated people that are concerned and
working towards finding a solution when
you're in a lab by yourself running
experiments you know you feel kind of
alone and to find that there's other
people that really care about it as well
you know it makes you feel good and it
feels like your research really matters
Thank below two degrees above
pre-industrial levels is quite a
challenge yeah illness
and what do you think our chances are
I've been encouraged in this meeting in
that science was up to the challenge and
I wasn't entirely sure before I came in
that was the case but I'm absolutely
confident that we have the technology we
have the brains and the power and the
people to do it it is then it just comes
down to political and personal wealth
and that's so I'm optimistic actually
very optimistic now with the science I'm
still hopeful about the political and
personal side of it we have to change
minds and changing minds doesn't happen
overnight you have to change policies
and that doesn't happen overnight I came
to lindo a week ago feeling deeply
concerned about the state of the planet
so having been here for a week at you I
feel well I still feel like we have
massive challenges ahead and that the
road to Copenhagen in December won't be
an easy one but having met some really
enthusiastic young researchers and some
of the best minds in atmospheric science
I feel that we're a bit closer to
solving the problem all of us we took
part in the crime at film this week have
come away with a renewed sense of
optimism I know the furrow and Brian
have both said that they feel more
optimistic and Brandi certainly said the
Chi feels really passionate about
dedicating her career to ocean health I
feel more optimistic about the
Copenhagen process I feel that we still
have massive challenges in the road
ahead and that it won't be easy getting
the political will we need to change our
world to change our whole energy system
as our economic system but what I do
feel is that we have the minds and the
tools to do that and that's something I
probably didn't feel a week ago
you